un rédigez un nouveau plan maintenant
nous sommes à la troisième étape de
notre projet pour parvenir à l'égalité
hommes-femmes pour moi c'est un grand
plaisir d'être le président du conseil
de l'arctique au cours des dernières
années et maintenant je donne la parole
au ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov et nous
espérons avoir une coopération réussie
dans le cadre du conseil sur votre prix
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mesdames messieurs comme l'a dit le
président sortant de soviets du conseil
arctique nous avons eu une session
parfaitement fructueuse intéressante et
constructive mais nous avons parlé des
salons tirer bilan des deux années
précédentes de présidence de l'islande
et nous avons préparé un plan pour les
deux années qui à venir et je tiens à
saluer les efforts considérables ont été
faits ce sont des efforts intellectuels
d'abord c'est durant ces deux dernières
années et quand je dis ça je dis je vois
que le premier document de perspectives
à long terme à avoir été signés de
l'histoire parle conseil article n'a pas
encore été
complètement validé mais en tout cas
c'est une étape importante et qui dont
le mérite revient évidemment la
présidence islandaise et je remercie nos
autres ils sont des pour l'organisation
de cette rencontre est ce leur accueil
chaleureux
nous avons pu traiter en d'état d'un
certain nombre de questions d'actualité
notamment liée à l'extension de la
coopération entre les baies article en
matière de développement durable de
préservation des langues et cultures des
peuples autochtones et des contacts
entre les populations et autour de ce
plan stratégique nous avons élaboré une
déclaration commune sur la coopération
dans les hautes latitudes et en faveur
de la poursuite de cette coopération
dans la zone arctique et comme je les
dis nous avons particulièrement apprécié
les efforts qui ont été faits par la
partie islandaise la russie comme
puissance arctique majeur a repris le
relais et donc va définir un certain
elle a défini déjà un certain nombre de
priorités en matière économique sociale
et environnementale et ce programme qui
a été validé par le gouvernement russe
montre notre engagement responsable dans
cette direction et notre attention sera
menée sur la mise en place de conditions
favorables pour la prospérité des
populations de la zone arctique avec
l'utilisation des potentiel intellectuel
et de recherche nationaux et notamment
la préservation de l'environnement
nous avons bien l'intention de continuer
à travailler avec l'ensemble des acteurs
du pays et pour lutter contre les
conséquences des effets anthropogène sur
le climat et l'environnement
et tout cela fait partie de notre agenda
de là que nous avons définies nous
favorisons la mise en place de nouvelles
technologies écologiques la mise en
place d'une économie circulaire les
carburants neutre le développement des
sources énergétiques renouvelables et
l'ensemble de la zone art et de rester
une zone de stabilité et de paix et il
ya un doit pas y avoir de potentiel de
conflit ici ne doit pas y avoir de
confrontation politico-militaire ici et
je vois que l'ensemble des participants
au conseil sont bien d'accord avec cette
position dont l'intérêt du maintien de
la paix de la stabilité nous avons
grandi
notre volonté de d'entretenir un
dialogue pluridirectionnel et en
conclusion encore une fois je tiens à
souligner le fait que la russie tout à
fait prête à développer les contacts
avec les participants permanent du
conseil avec les observateurs et les
autres pays partenaires
il ya un certain nombre de partenaires
qui ont le statut d'observateurs tout
des pays et des organisations qui sont
cinq fois plus nombreux que les pays
membres eux-mêmes et donc c'est une
réflexion sur la façon de rechercher et
de trouver des solutions satisfaisantes
en matière de la défense des intérêts
des peuples de la zone arctique et cet
esprit de coopération nous allons le
renforcer dans un dans une atmosphère de
confiance et de compréhension mutuelle
je vous remercie passer aux questions la
première question commerçante
vous avez souligné que le camp c'est de
l'article est une plate forme du
dialogue dépolitiser mais selon vous ces
confrontations dans d'autres domaines
ne peut-elle être présente aussi dans le
domaine de l'arctique et la deuxième
question vous avez proposé de reprendre
les contacts entre militaires s'étaient
propositions at elle été bien reçue par
votre partenaire un jeu j'ai parlé à
réunions qui ont eu ici à reykjavik j'ai
aussi une question à messiers thordarson
évaluez vous la proposition russe de
reprendre le dialogue entre les
militaires bien autour du nous partons
du principe que au sein du conseil
arctique l'eia son programme propre qui
définit pas seulement un emploi du temps
mais un agent d'armé qui propose aussi
un certain nombre de procédures de
mise en oeuvre pour être bref c'est un
consensus qui fait l'objet ici faits qui
concernent l'ensemble des discussions
que nous avons eues au conseil arctique
et je dirais que c'est une des rares
organisations où on trouve toujours un
consensus par les efforts généraux de
l'ensemble des membres des partis et
sans s'adresser d'ultimatum et des se
tordent le bras dans le dos etc
on se comprend très bien il ya cette
tradition de dialogue qui se maintient
et en effet hier lors de la discussion
au dîner informel ne j'ai posé un
certain nombre de questions qui se
posent aujourd'hui qui concernent
aujourd'hui je dirais pas qu'ils
qu'elles apparaissent aujourd'hui dans
le contexte mais plutôt qu'elles peuvent
révéler plutôt certains aspects du
programme notamment de l'otan dans la
zone arctique
par exemple la proximité de nos
frontières ou voir on voit sans cesse
des rotations militaires qui sont
effectuées et on voit que certains de
nos voisins modifier leur disposition
légale pour pouvoir accueillir des
contingents étrangers armés
il ya encore eu régulière récemment une
un séminaire sur les opérations
militaires dans la zone arctique
donc c'était en gros le conseil arctique
- la russie plus quatre pays de l'otan
france grande bretagne allemagne et un
autre pays
et donc cette discussion cette rencontre
s'est faite mais de se demander à nos
partenaires du conseil arctique de bien
considérer cette histoire est d'éviter
toute situation où la question de la
sécurité serait sortie des accords que
nous auquel nous sommes parvenus en
discutons nous on semble donc nous avons
rappeler encore une fois que comme nous
l'avons déjà fait dans le passé il ya eu
un certain nombre de rencontres qui ont
été faites au niveau des chefs d'état
major des pays membres du conseil
arctique
il a été question de navigation maritime
il était question d'exploitation
pétrolière et de d'action anthropogène
néfastes pour l'environnement et pour un
certain nombre de raisons depuis 2014
les pays occidentaux ont décidé de
casser ces mécanismes qui fonctionnait
entre noter aujourd'hui ce mécanisme est
interrompue mais nous considérons que
nous avons tout à fait les forces
nécessaires pour reprendre ces
discussions reprendre ce dialogue au
bleu au niveau parce que c'est un
partenariat qui est important et nous
avons proposé de mener des consultations
au niveau des experts militaires
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas encore
eu de réactions positives
notre la balle est dans le camp de nos
partenaires et nous allons continuer à
réunir les conditions de façon à ce que
ces discussions sur la sécurité
collective puisse poursuivre au sein du
conseil et articles de l'article merci
général et fondateur du conseil de
l'arctique avait raison
en prenant la décision de couette une
organisation cette organisation la base
d'un consensus comme ça qu'est la france
vient de le lire
quand même nous examinons également les
questions liées à la sécurité il est
important de maintenir ces attitudes les
raisons que nous avons examinées mais il
ya des raisons pour laquelle nous avons
pas revenu au grand succès notre
organisation doit rester tel quel et
tout ce qu'on peut faire en tant que
pippo réduire les tensions pour assurer
la sécu de la stabilité et l'important
de prendre ces mesures mais ce qui est
important c'est de maintenir la
structure et l'ordre de fonctionnement
du pont c'est la question suivante
merci monsieur lavrov la russie s'est
dit préoccupé par le renforcement de la
coopération militaire entre norvège les
états unis est selon en russie la russie
que pense-t-elle des activités
américaines
un grand monde est ce que ces activités
ont une importance stratégique la russie
envisage-t-elle d'investir un conte
landes pendant que la chine et les états
unis
de tels projets merci nous avons déjà
sur fois donné des commentaires sur la
situation qui est liée à l'augmentation
de la présence militaire à nos
frontières et nous avons encore une fois
discuté de cette question avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères de
norvège lorsque notre voisin la norvège
qui n'avait jamais été légalement
impliqué sur une présence militaire
aujourd'hui on procéder à des
amendements à la loi
et tout cela va dans le sens que il y à
des rotations de présence militaire
donc nous observons cette présence
militaire dans d'autres pays européens
et ce qui nous préoccupe en premier
blanc à nos frontières
parce que la norvège est un autre voisin
le plus proche avec lequel nous avons
d'excellentes relations
mais les problèmes sont liés au
renforcement des pressions
militaires et politiques avec des
présences dans les pays scandinaves et
dans les pays baltes et nos lois et
notre volonté de préserver notre
sécurité et c'est ce qui avait été
proposé de jean ii en 1997 de le conseil
russie otan
il avait été convenu qu' il n'y aurait
pas d'augmentation des contingents
militaires et des armements et je
propose de jeux profitent de cette
situation pour dire qu'elle ne doit pas
y avoir d'augmentation alors on joue sur
les mots ici avec les présence
permanente où les rotations et c'est
trahir justement j'ai posé des questions
à anthony blinken sur ce projet et
qu'elle est j'ai demandé quelle était
qu'est-ce qui allait y avoir encore
comme infraction aux accords sur le plan
de la présence militaire au pologne
parce que tous les pays
l'otan comprennent bien que les
discussions ne sont pas seulement
bilatérales mais elles sont des
questions multilatérales ici qui
concerne la sécurité de la fédération de
russie
et il faut bien comprendre que nous
voulons pas seulement mener un dialogue
sur les relations entre les deux pays
mais sur l'ensemble du problème du
contrôle des armements et de la non
prolifération des armements et j'espère
bien que dans le cas de l'oas heures
puisqu'il ya un forum qui existe et qui
est dédié à cela on trouvera une façon
de discuter et que les actions
unilatérales cesseront avec des
exercices militaires majeures qui sont
faits à la juste là le long des
frontières de là aussi nous voulons que
le dialogue sur lequel nous nous étions
entendus au début se poursuivent sur la
sécurité en europe et dans les années 90
au niveau de la charte de paris par
exemple de la déclaration de d'istanbul
il était clairement écrit que les
questions de sécurité de la ce doivent
se faire avec la présence des structures
régionales militaires qui sont concernés
et qui doivent participer quel qu'il
s'agisse de l'eau et soeurs ou de l'otan
nous avons déjà essayé plus que la grèce
était à l'époque présidente nous avions
il y avait le secrétaire général de
l'otan il y avait les représentants de
la celui des représentants de l'eau à ce
que les représentants de la politique
étrangère européenne et depuis nous
n'avons rien pu organiser de pareils et
tout blog sur le fait que l'otan ce
qu'on sait se considère comme plus égale
que les autres et d'autres qu'elle ne va
pas s'abaisser au niveau du dialogue et
c'est pas seulement le c'est pas le seul
exemple de mépris on voit ces dernières
années de plus en plus de manifestations
sur l'arène internationale de ce genre
de comportement est doux tirerons des
conclusions et nous prendrons les
mesures nécessaires pour que tous ceux
qui puisse menacer tout ce qui peut
menacer notre sécurité puisse être
réglée et autant possible dans le
dialogue
après en ce qui concerne le groenland
c'est il les passe juste à côté de nos
frontières nous mais c'est une décision
qui relève de la volonté du gouvernement
du danemark et c'est à lui de voir
sur le plan intérieur sur la façon dont
les relations entre copenhague et le
groenland sous gérer nous venons de
discuter avec un représentant des îles
faroe et et représentant de l'ong et
dans le cadre de cette discussion des
ministres du conseil de l'arctique pour
nous avons parlé aussi là aussi les
relations avec la chine niall des
projets commerciaux donc un certain
nombre de deux programmes assez globaux
qui mériterait d'être étendu on avait
parlé par exemple organiser peut-être
des défauts robe notamment dans le cadre
du forum économique international de
saint-pétersbourg par exemple la
troisième question médias je tiens
un président sortant de parler des
questions de sécurité le problème de
préoccupation du par la population du
nord la préoccupation et par le
renforcement des activités militaires
quelles réponses pourriez-vous donner à
ces préoccupations comme le vous l'avez
dit vous-même
ces questions me trouvais déjà posé je
ne peux que confirmer que je ne vois pas
de problème dans l'argent qui doivent
être résolus par la voie militaire
les conseils article ce que de
l'arctique ne sont pas de questions
strictement militaire de sécurité mais
en tout cas il ne dispose de mécanismes
qui permettent de
de traiter de ces questions et des
problèmes qui peuvent surgir notamment
en matière de sauvetage en cas de
catastrophe naturelle et cette pratique
a été historique a été restaurée quand
il s'agit de la réduction des tensions
comme sage et de stabilité
en ce qui concerne la sécurité le
travail du conseil contribuer à la
résolution de ce problème on ne serait
estimé le travail d
un groupe d'experts groupe de travail
est nécessaire d'assurer la stabilité
dans la région de l'arctique c'est un
travail essentiel nous nous occupons de
ce travail est depuis vingt cinq ans
nous sommes ravis que l'ensemble des
membres du conseil sont prêts à pousser
poursuivre ce travail même si ces
questions ne sont pas liés directement
au travail du conseil il est nécessaire
d'établir un dialogue à ce sujet et
tenir des négociations constructives
c'est c'est essentiel merci monsieur le
ministre il ya la dernière question à
monsieur dansant à la dernière question
sera posée par la chaîne par chaîne et
selon deux jeunes qui sont mis sur la
preuve vous avez dit que vous souhaitez
que les un chef des armées se réunissent
pour discuter des questions militaires
avec quelles pourraient être les
résultats dans d'une telle réunion
que pensez vous c'est la question à
laquelle j'ai déjà répondu quatre fois
c'est à dire la propose de voir les
questions militaires au sein du conseil
de quartier jeudi que cette pratique
existait notre proposition consiste
simplement à reprendre cette tradition
c'est à dire que les chefs d'état major
les responsables militaires puissent
avoir la possibilité de
discuter sur les questions qui peuvent
se poser quotidiennement notamment
encore une fois quand il y à des
catastrophes naturelles en matière de
navigation maritime les opérations de
recherche et de sauvetage pour les
navires en détresse
et hier lors de notre discussion avec
monsieur blinken nous en avons parlé il
ya déjà des déclarations qui circulent
sur internet et dans les réseaux sociaux
monsieur thordarson merci fauveau
intervention merci d'avoir participé à
notre conférence de presse bon journée